[Music]
if we plan to make chocolate milk for a
family then we will add ingredients like
milk sugar and chocolate in a
proportionate amount right now what if
we have guests at home we will simply
have to double or triple the amount of
individual ingredients simple isn't it
it means that for a particular recipe
the proportion of inputs will almost
always remain the same why are we
discussing this along with the concept
of atoms that's because it will help us
understand a few important laws related
to atoms the introduction to the concept
of atoms was a major breakthrough in the
field of chemistry however proving the
existence of atoms needed many
experimental evidences the hypothesis
that matter is formed out of atoms
needed experimental evidences soon a
French chemist called Antoine Lavoisier
carried out several experiments to
finalize some strong and valid concepts
after remarkable observations and
ideologies we could get the two major
laws of chemical combinations the two
laws are law of conservation of mass and
law of constant proportions let us
understand each law in detail let's take
a simple example just imagine we carry
out an experiment in which element a and
element B react together to give us a
compound C if we keenly observed we find
that atoms of elements a and B do not
exist individually in the reaction
mixture they come together to give us
the new compound C although it seems
that atoms of elements a and B are
degenerating it's not the case in
reality they are combining to give us
the compound C Antoine Lavoisier
put forth the law of conservation of
mass and do you know what it tells us
it states that mass can neither be
created nor destroyed in a chemical
reaction he explains this law by saying
that matter is formed from the
pre-existing matter and the mass of the
newly formed matter will be the same as
that of the pre-existing
we can either create new matter not
destroy the existing matter so the
chocolate milk that we made in the
beginning came from the milk sugar and
chocolate mixed together similarly we
could see that compound C is formed only
when atoms of elements a and B combined
together so new substances are formed
only when pre-existing ones combine in
nature new things cannot be made from
nothing the input for any matter that's
formed is always the matter that already
exists now this was the first law do you
remember the second law yes it was the
law of constant proportions but for
knowing this law in detail you will have
to watch our next video
[Music]
you